So the first technique that we will consider is Tomasulo's algorithm.
It's really one of the first techniques for out-of-order execution and
now it's more than 40 years old. It was used in the old IBM 360 machines,
which are now, again, more than 40 years old.
What it does is it determines which instructions have inputs ready so
that they can go in the next cycle and which instructions still have to wait for
their inputs to be produced. It also includes a form of register renaming, and
it is surprisingly similar to what we actually use today as far as
out-of-order execution is concerned. So although this is more than 40 years old,
it actually is very useful to know how it works because it's kind of like
the first approach, so it's simpler than what we use today, but it really well
explains what's going on. The differences between Tomasulo's algorithm and
what is used today are only that in the olden days,
when Tomasulo's algorithm was implemented, they did that only for
floating point instructions, while today, we do it for all instructions. Also,
they had relatively few instructions in the window that they're looking at,
meaning they only really looked over some small number of instructions into the,
you know, future instructions that need to be executed well today.
We look at hundreds instructions past the one we are still executing.
In the olden days, exception handling for
floating point instructions was not such a big problem, because they were only
considering really execution of kind of floating point extensive applications.
And you know, those will be programmed and so on, and you would usually run one
program at a time. If there is an exception, you could do some drastic measures.
Today, process include explicit support for exception handling that we will see
later. So we first again look at how the Tomasulo's algorithm did it and
then we consider how today's processors do these additional things.